ah la la la la la la la la
aujourd'hui mon coeur est là mais mon
coeur est meurtri et oui j'ai appris
tout à l'heure dans l'après midi car des
chroniqueurs de l'émission avait été
interpellé par la maréchaussée
oui oui je l' ai appris on me baladant
sur les différents sites d'information
pas si on peut appeler ça des sites
d'information pour certains et j'ai vu
ça j'ai été donc pas bien et j'ai dit il
faut qu'on parle aux français
donc on parle aux téléspectateurs de
touche pas à mon poste que s'est il
vraiment passé c'est pour ça que les
chroniqueurs ne sont pas encore là c'est
une affaire entre lui et moi
une affaire entre mon fils et moi
jean michel maire entre et s'il vous
plaît de la police est plein
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui
[Musique]
ne jugeons pas avant de savoir
jean michel maire fait donc partie de
touche pas à mon poste depuis le 1er
avril 2010 des tuiles à 2 lors de la
première émission détient garçon sage un
journaliste journaliste sur qui on
pouvait compter journalistes qui se
couchait tôt un journaliste s'occuper de
sa famille aujourd'hui aux yeux des gens
vous êtes un loubard par lui que c'est
ici que s'est il passé
j'ai entendu dire ici et là que vous
étiez fait interpeller donc cette nuit
les gens va démarrer que s'est-il passé
hier soir après l'émission qui avait
fait qu avez-vous vu qu avez-vous
entendu
après j'ai une vraie oui tout ça et va
est malheureusement vrai nom mais après
j'ai été invité à dîner auquel je me
suis rendu et après un ami
malheureusement m'a appelé pour me dire
qu'il y avait un copain dj qui mixe et
dans une boîte à paris à gauche un dj
déjà vous avez des copains dj ses
limites
je me suis rendu je comptais rester
qu'une heure évidemment une heure plus
1h égale trois heures à 8 heures du
matin égale à 8 heures du matin et voilà
et là je savais qu'il fallait pas
prendre mon scoop donc je supplie les
ravens avaient jamais vu
donc évidemment ma boîte on moi bah moi
je vois pas en boîte à voilà ça c'est un
problème mais moi malheureusement j'ai
bu et ça c est ma très grande faute donc
surtout ne faut pas le faire on se
retrouve pas prendre l état d'ébriété
j'étais mais j'ai roulé normalement je
m'en fous le terme échu y compris que
vous vouliez pas au zig zag
oui c'est ça ah non vous vouliez
normalement vous avez pris votre
véhicule en état d'ébriété jean-michel
mais ce lancement scooter oui cgt pas on
est urgent étant ce qu est ce que vous
êtes non là pour parler un peu sérieuse
est conscient que vous avez mis en
danger votre vie et la vie des autres
oui
non mais c'est clair mais je me suis pas
fait arrêter parce que je zigzague et
comme vous avez pu voir je me suis
arrêté pour plaque salle
pas de bol
attendez vous êtes en train de me dire
que même votre plaque voilà votre image
évidemment salle au feu il ya le
contrôle et quand on les aime
oui mais c'est sûr tu est d'admettre que
neil à mon avis quand vous n'ayez pas
qu'elles se sont passées
voilà et donc du coup après la garde à
vue du tout j'ai lu ici et là que garde
à vue j'ai l'impression que j'avais une
course poursuite dans tout paris que la
police doit s'arrêter au feu il me
ranger le scout j'étais au commissariat
on a fait un test d'alcoolémie positif
ouais bah oui ça oui voilà et après j'ai
attendu en discutant avec les polices et
du viiie arrondissement que de paris
monde il qui adore les missions qui ont
dit leur fait une dédicace et j'ai
attendu avec eux que bas que je sois que
je puisse repartir parce qu'ils n'ont
pas leur avoue l'été n'est pas bu des
coups avec eux non non mais on est
obligés d'attendre d'eux que le taux
soit redescendue parce que autrement
c'est attendu presque 24 jade
non il a attendu jusqu'à un millier de
milles en mer de 8 est donc là
aujourd'hui
lala maintenant vous est sobre je suis
sobre oui mais j'étais savons
s'entendait comme ça et à 12h30 là pour
revenir sérieusement cette affaire on
voulait tout dire aux téléspectateurs
donc parce qu'on a vu partout que
c'était sorti ça a été fait ça fait une
affaire d'état
en tout cas vous regrettez mine de rien
d'avoir pris vos trousses qu'amateur et
manquons belle en état d'ébriété vous ne
le ferez plus bas c'est une mode vous
avez combien de points en moins
ah bah ça je sais pas je vais convoquer
après je sais pas vous mais là c'est la
cimenterie trois ans me dire ses 8
points maximum en moi j'ai tout légers
toujours quoique ciment mais j'ai jamais
eu un point de retirer
ouais ouais mais non mais ça faut plus
le faire jean michel harel bien chabason
n'offrait plus c'est une bonne leçon
battant de taxi taxi taxi
voilà bon maintenant vous savez ce que
vous allez faire ça laisse quand bien
sûr je pense à tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent à toutes les familles qui nous
regarde on est quand même une émission
familiale lui donnait pas le bon exemple
à bages et j'en suis conscient et ben là
vous allez donner le bon exemple quand
vous allez faire des travaux
l'intérêt voilà pour la france général
exactement où d'un terreau d'intérêt
général mairie même avec des général ou
des généraux mettre des caporal vous
allez donc sortir et laver les voitures
des pas sont d'accord non michèle merli
mais les voitures de police ou si toutes
les voitures d'accord jean-michel
d'accord merci jean michel vous avez eu
quand même
la franchise de dire ce qui s'était
vraiment passé merci jean michel
[Applaudissements]